le week-end a été pour de nombreuses
régions le dernier moment de respiration
avant un contournement qui s'est
généralisé à toute la france
mais alors que la consommation d'alcool
est interdite et les déplacements
limités de nombreux français ont été
verbalisés c'est par exemple la mauvaise
expérience qu'il raconte ses habitants
de l'hérault qui ont dû payer des
amendes d'un total de 405 euros pour
avoir vu du rosé en famille sur la plage
comme il le raconte au midi libre
c'était notre dernier moment pour se
retrouver avant de se confiner ce moment
a été gâchée mais au delà de la fermeté
de ces mesures ce père de famille
reproche également la forme très
violente de cette répression sont
arrivés à plusieurs avec leur arme de
poing il y a des enfants avec nous vous
imaginez l'image pour eux en effet sur
des images publiées sur twitter il est
possible de voir que certains gendarmes
sont équipé d'équipements militaires
telles que des fusils d'assaut et des
gilets pare-balles une répression qui a
choqué de nombreux français ce week-end
alors des gendarmes équipés de fusils
d'assaut pour contrôler les français un
scandale
tony hawk est avec nous comme à san
antonio déjà bonsoir pme en tonneau
bonsoir il est dans le truc ça y est il
est dans là il est dans la téloche
anthony ya beaucoup de gens qui te vous
croyez qu'on croyait qu antonio n'est
encore non public voulu dire quelles
habitudes et notre public antonio nommé
tp je suis là non plus il marque pas
j'adore parce qu'il n'ya pas un micro
qui marche donc antonio va faire le tour
de table et pendant ce temps on va
équiper un t'inquiète pas on a des
micros il ya un magasin qui ont ouvert
juste à droite première à droite
sonos déco merci oui alors vous
comprenez alors attendez attendez il
paraît qu'il ya que moi qui ai un micro
pour l'instant tout a sauté il ya que
moi qui peut parler donc voilà donc
cesser voilà c'est ça ccc ccc pour ça
c'est pour ça qu'ont donc comme par
hasard à bâle coûté je veux donner mon
avis non mais alors allez-y vous voulez
parler et il n'y a que mon micro qui
marche un grab alesi a dit jeudi que tu
aimes dans un monde de fous et que ça
envoie je trouve un signal de dictature
il ya dix policiers et quatre plages et
on n'a plus droit de rien faire on n'a
plus droit de sortir on n'a plus droit
de manger on n'a plus droit à voir des
amis on a droit de faire quoi à part
télétravail est en fête et géraldine
n'est pas d'accord la seo play jura
n'est pas d'accord alors dictature tu
dis vraiment n'importequoi lieu mais
c'est pas la première fois moi je pose
aucun problème
après tout on peut y avoir d y avoir des
militaires comme ça dans les aéroports
dans les gares les enfants ça les
traumatise pas y'a pas combien ils sont
là pour faire respecter
mais les tenues les tenues à ça ça vous
fait pas un pli permis à m ils vont pas
se mettre en tongs et ans
paréo sous prétexte qu'on est au tour
sur la plage n'y a pas de problème ils
sont dans leur ils sont dans leur dans
leur costume de travail voilà il ya
aucun jean michel jarre libère vous
organisation brenda petit quelque chose
a averti les policiers dans la journée
il devait être prêt à n'importe quelle
intervention l'iphone du contrôle sur la
plage et sont les appels pour une action
de permis sont maintenant dire j'en
parle et là on leur valeur dire genre à
nantes attend les chefs où je rentre au
commissariat ont changé chez pentu ils
sont ils se préparent au pire ils font
aussi les deux super sont plus banal
mais sont préparés au pire c'est tout
oui et veut pas
oui bonsoir ils sont pas équipés rihanna
moi je suis proche de vous ils sont pas
hippiques et l'équipe et pour aller sur
la page facebook qui sont équipés comme
ça et qu'ils un contrôle sur la plage il
se sent évidemment par nachi
spécialement pour ça c'est une évidence
c'est totalement délirant ce que je
viens d'entendre ce sont des équipements
réservés pour des tueries ou pour des
drames il ya des gens sur la plage que
l'on contrôle à qui on met une amende et
c'est légitime mais ses tenues sont
totalement disproportionnées par rapport
aux infractions des gens
franchement je trouve ça scandaleux au
menu danse émoi les micros un merci
l'attaqué c'est à dire moi je dis que
moi ça me rassure parce que quand ils
sont par mais on dit qu'on sent pas en
sécurité et canton f
quand on les voir mais on se plaint et
moi je pense que même sur une plage on
est tellement dans un monde de fou en ce
moment on peut tomber aussi encore sur
un taré donc on en a marre qu'on tabasse
sur les flics ont ils en prennent pas la
gueule et ils sont là pour notre pour
notre sécu
ce taux ils sont là pour notre sécurité
alors ça très bien oui alors nicolas
pernikoff ils sont policiers du début à
la fin de la journée donc vos envies de
couronnes orbi effectivement qui se
mettent en maillot de bain il préférait
être en maillot de bain je pense surtout
aux plages de prato randonnée ils sont
comme ça toute la journée je vois pas
pourquoi il se mettrait enfin je vois
pas ce qui peut choquer on aura antonio
de talent il ya des jockeys oui mais
j'arrive c'est pas la peine de lever la
main 80 la sallaz nom ne soit possible
demande pas de nom mais ne pas avoir de
cuisine ont vu c'est quand même une
petite famille avait un enfant qui est
elle un donc ça fait très peur ça fait
peur je suis désolé il ferait mieux de
se déplacer dans un temps pas l'aide
dont on parlera tout à l'heure plutôt
des pauvres gens qui ont plus en plus
405 euros d'amande ou là elle veut
dénoncer celle ci 1
attention alors bien alors petits yeux
dit j'ai écouté dans franchement vous
êtes au pays des bisounours sont des
policiers ils sont en armes c'est tout à
fait normal y'a rien de choquant là
dessus voilà c'est tout c'est tout la
prochaine fois je passerai à lui un
merci antonio alors antonio lui il est
pas content même pas du tout à un moment
donné je pense qu'il a eu complètement
raison simple dictature quand on voit le
gamin qui a fait 100 blessés
si je suis venu pour m'exprimer pour je
puisse m'exprimer je vois la gamme un
plat c'est pour rire bordel de merde
voilà une heure de route
quand je vois un gamin qui a l'âge de
mon fils moi je pense qu'à son âge je
vois autant de gens autour de mon papa
une maman qui sont tranquillement sur un
pique nique franchement je flippe et ça
traumatise pour me dire ce que vous
voulez depuis que ce gouvernement est là
c'est un pays de dictature point barre
alors qu'ils me répondent qu'il veut
répondre
j'attends des gens et je vais à j'arrive
s'il vous plaît j'arrive je serai pas
toujours là antonio jour mois sur la
tête de ses enfants qui tuera pas jeter
les armes en plastique et des enfants un
jour de alors sincèrement oui en tant
qu'ancien militaire je fais mes enfants
ont des armes mais par contre une chose
laisse moi finir mais attendu m'a posé
une question je vais te répondre si je
peux me permettre de tutoyer
quand je quand avec ton papa sur la
plage que tu vas passer un bon moment et
que tu vois ton papa qui se fait
contrôler par une vingtaine de flics
armés jusqu'aux dents c'est un pays de
dictature point barre c'est tout y a pas
à tergiverser donc et moi nous il est le
désordre et les ou le désordre
j'ai en train de manger un chantre
moufek mes gamins mais ça va pas ou quoi
regarde les armes de guerre
novelli jopek d'abord d'abord benjamin
c'est pas des policiers et des gendarmes
ces gendarmes ce sont des militaires qui
sont préparés pour des actions contre
des gens extrêmement violent ils sont
sur une plage franchement c'est
l'irrespect des gens comment voulez vous
après que les gens respect mais benjamin
comment voulez vous que les genres échec
les forces de l'ordre quant aux pas
abouti comment faites vous et toi
abrutis voilà oh non pas ça tonio je
t'aime beaucoup mais ce que tu as déjà
vécu dans une stature ont parlé comme ça
non mais moi j'ai déjà été dans des pays
hôtes naturels de villégiature foot
arrive sur la place d'un village tout
son appareil photo est largement j'adore
ta tempe a entonné un tabac
on va je vais arriver sur ses pas mais
sauvé par les attentats manteau de
mandature c'est ça ma chair et d'os de
la turbine équatoriale arrive ce rappel
ce jeu là tout seul appareil photos et
imitateurs tu fais arrêter sur sa la csn
dictature mais moi c'est au beurre vous
entend pas alors les cherry on en train
de régler pour rennes de son vous
réagissez énormément à tout ça et c'est
vrai que regarder un sur twitter il ya
eu beaucoup beaucoup de réactions et si
cette photo de cet article de midi libre
voilà caf voilà qui a posé problème
c'est vrai que quand on la revoit il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent c'est quand
même fière quand même il ya quand même
beaucoup de monde voilà le guillaume
caisse c'est vrai que sans dire que
c'était une dictature je suis d'accord
que ça envoie un signal de dictature on
ne peut plus rien faire on peut plus on
peut plus aller à la plage en famille on
veut plus on peut plus parler que ses
amis on peut plus sortir on est autorisé
à ne rien faire à part faire du
télétravail chez soi depuis un an mais
vous rendez compte c'est n'importe quand
own you antonio en antonio que quand
rabeschi ce qui m'embête le plus c'est
qu'on a des moutons en france qui laisse
faire ce genre de choses
personnellement moi je suis horripilé de
voir ce genre d'image surtout pour le
gamin qui me fait penser à mon fils
sincèrement vous êtes tous là au 30 vous
plaindre et si et ça mais sincèrement qu
est ce qui se passe on peut plus sortir
on peut bouffer ce qu'on veut bientôt va
aller aux chiottes on aura une caméra
dans le cul je suis désolé d'être mode
d'être vulgaire alors je les ai par
contre je ne devrais pas chambre avait
pas d'équipé je te le dis antonio je
t'aime beaucoup mais je note je
n'enverrais pas des équipes aa là je
crois que géraldine veut réagir antonio
parce que c'est vrai que géraldine alors
vous êtes contre l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
mais bien sûr que oui et il est contre
l'exigence quelqu'un de votre famille
tombe malade vous voulez pas qu'il aille
on attend de 2 minutes
2 mai le donner autant pas tu sais on
est donc on et voilà on est on est dans
une
on a peu de moyens alors ce qui est une
aberration cclat peu près un an j'ai mis
une vidéo sur pasteur on m'a traité de
fou et je passe en attendant ce que tu
as aimé survivre mais c'est pas ça c'est
que c'est compliqué c'est pas compliqué
la vidéo que j'avais fait sur l'institut
pasteur et madame busin et toute la
clique c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
on m'a traité de fou même dans cette
émission on m'a traitée de complotiste à
ce jour tout ce que j'ai dit me dites
moi ce qui est faux dites moi ce qu'il
faut là aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est
que ce gouvernement a mis en place une
dictature qu'on le veuille ou non est le
pire et le pire et le pire c'est que
c'est vous même qui traîne ce qui fait
vos papiers et vous vous autorisez vous
même à sortir pour une maladie qui fait
excuser moi un virus qui fait 05 peau de
mortalité ça veut dire que sur 100
personnes en a cinq personnes qui
meurent c'est pas le virus est pas là
que gps pagnol on a aujourd'hui beaucoup
mais c'est beaucoup mais il faut arrêter
d'en amplifier les choses
ouais c'est quand même beaucoup
jean-michel mère attendait jean michel
tôt minute deux minutes j'arrive à vous
savez moi je vois des grands chefs je ne
sais pas ça être épuisé pour tonio
antonio des zones te dire mais si on
laissait personne que tu vois pas le
droit de parler en ce moment je serai
pas à la télévision tout prépa pas si
cyril vous aime beaucoup
honteux d'employer le mot dictature pour
un pays que la france
on s'en doute un des pays qui ne fait
pas assez mais qui fait beaucoup plus
que bien d'autres seront démocratiques
non chaleur accord et vous madame est
très bonne nouvelle
la micro marche alors là c'est moins sûr
étant le sien c'est bon tu peux prendre
celui que tu as déjà celui que j'ai déjà
pas du tout moi je vous respecte tous
énormément c'est vrai merde partir du
moment à partir du moment où on entend
ou on voit ce genre de d'image pour moi
vous pouvez pas me dire que si on va
prendre la chose très simple pour
connaître le futur il faut regarder le
passé si je vous aurais dit à 10 ans de
cela un jour vous ne pourrez pas aller
au restaurant
un jour vous ne pourrez pas sortir alors
que vous souhaitez l'autre jour je
faisais mes courses
j'entends une annonce on aurait pu la
mettre en allemand cette annonce
monsieur je suis désolé collaborateurs
vous rentrez chez vous nicolas comme ça
encore nicolas on a encore en train de
parler d'abord lui une image celle où la
gendarmerie ne savait pas ce qui se
passe là bas et ce qu'ils sont en état
d' alerte parce qu'en ce moment on est
en état d' alerte sanitaire non mais
aussi en état d' alerte générale il ya
des risques aujourd'hui être gendarme ou
policier sur le sol français vous le
savez ils peuvent se faire attaquer par
des profs activement sur ariège avec des
arrêtés vous êtes avec des arrivées dans
ta de caricaturer la police avait pas du
tout que j'aurais peut-être que la
police qui a alors je respecte la police
et à plus de soixante deux mille
personnes infectées c'est à dire on a un
record depuis la dernière fois et qu'il
ya une vraie urgence sanitaire dans
l'autre bien sûr et c'est pour cela
qu'on vous interdis aller à la plage 3
persos d'espacé 2 5 mètres de distance
effectivement armés jusqu'aux dents mais
la seule chose que vous avez oublier
monsieur en tant qu'être humain est ce
que vous avez des enfants oui ou non
moi je suis à la place du petit garçon
était par terre d'accord et ben moi
c'est vrai aujourd'hui non laissez le
parler comme s'ils ont des valeurs et
moi quand j'ai un contrôle sur le sur le
lait les voiles et les voies de
circulation les enfants dont j'ai déjà
sont un petit peu aux stress mais là sur
la plage un jour d agresser moi finir ce
que voulait sortir une wii bas avec
l'excusé mois quand les c'est ce
monsieur est une arme de guerre de vous
je sais pas que ce gouvernement au lieu
d'investir au du d'investir dans les
shows sanitaire abc dans des armes et là
vous le savez très légèrement
jean-michel quand jean-michel suis très
bien chez les enfants ne n'ont pas la
même vision que nous l ordre de la
qualité et les enfants passent leur
temps à regarder les séries ultra
violents des voûtes quotidien les jours
à venir ils sont commis pour elle et
justin laisse ayew 62 ans
non je suis désolé
un enfant à cet âge là ils impriment il
imprima autrement il ne perçoit pas la
réalité comme vous et moi ne me dites
pas que quand il voit son papa après qui
se mange une chose comment papa va lui
expliquer à son fils
bah écoutes je termine à la plage est
bien la personne les percées 105 euros
d'amande et si le papa il est au smig
il explique qu'au ghana tue-mouches quoi
la fin du mois c'est comme ça qu'il faut
réaliser monsieur les choses et les
regarder et pas seulement de votre
petite vision qui est obtus moi moi j'ai
eu hier il faut il faut et j'aime bien
avoir l'avis d'antonio moi tout est là
parce que bah oui parce que haïti il dit
pas antonio c'est y voilà il explique
les choses est échue si on va voir le
sondage dans un instant mais il y en a
autour de la table est-ce que notre la
dame qui sont d'accord expédié en audio
gilles guillaume
voilà donc déjà au tour de table ils
sont trois donc
ils épient n'est pas seul non plus au
monde guillon tu parles de soixante deux
mille personnes infectées alors je suis
d'accord c'est dramatique mais combien
de millions de français sont au bout de
leur vie n'ont plus de raison de vivre
peuvent même pas aller à la plage avec
leurs enfants parlent de l'après midi
des policiers des images illustrent
quelque chose et qu'on me regarde et me
regardait les policiers ils n'omettent
pas d'armes messagerie vidéo bien
quelque chose c'est que quand on est à 3
en train de pique-niquer sur une plage
vous avez dit policiers armés je suis
désolé en termes de signal c'est quand
même dramatique alors jugé y avait
quelqu'un sait pas s'il ya des personnes
qui disent antonio ce sont des
équipements réglementaires huyghe
peloton de surveillance et
d'intervention de la gendarmerie et les
gendarmes sont toujours en déploiement
vigipirate a l'air et l'attentât d'acte
prisé du fait qu'ils sont là ils sont
combien sur la plage mais non mais sans
rire mais entre nous on sait jamais
cette image est ok jamais dit qu'on n'a
pas besoin arrêtez de me faire venir
kaka date les policiers répondre c'est
antonio mais attendez moi je suis
d'accord mais ne croyez pas que je suis
un anti flics arrêtent est le parrain de
ma fille est un officier de gendarmerie
alors mais regrettait les choses en
place et je vous dis juste le terme mais
je fait un sondage un jour sur l'ordre
nature et vous verrez en france la maman
vous coupe les empêchent de sortir c'est
la dictature de la marraine de matisse
et capitaine marleau moi je trouve que
la manière dont nicolas et jean michel
par la antonio excusez moi mais non plus
qui respecte et je vais dire un moteur
jolie ont respecté entre nous il sait
très bien que la coque sur plein de
crise quel contenu lui mais on
s'apprécie déroulée jeudi en haïti mais
je tenais dans mes on se respecte
beaucoup mais c'est quelqu'un voilà
jeunes qui s'expriment bien antonio ici
toutes les idées un ses bras elles sont
là pour être des matches couperets
rassure voilà c'est quelqu'un voilà même
si je vous dis on n'est pas d'accord son
club riccobono mais j'étais quelqu'un
que j'aime beaucoup je voulais juste
répondent à une petite chose vous me
parlez de dictature d'accord la seule
personne à ce jour qui m'a permis de
m'exprimer non non non vous avez dit
qu'on n'est pas dans un pays de
dictature
quand vous faites une vidéo et vous vous
avez été touchés je me rappelle de ce
qui vous est arrivé vous mais plus aucun
droit de réponse par rapport à
l'agression que vous avez subie sur les
réseaux moi j'ai eu ma vidéo
j'ai eu zéro droit de réponse pourquoi
parce que toi était cadenassé la seule
personne qui m'a donné la possibilité de
m'exprimer à ce jour ainsi que sur les
gilet jaune c'est cyril les autres
médias pendant quelques mois
à 0 0 0 0 votre combat je trouve noble
je comprends très bien ce que vous dites
mais on peut pas prendre une photo et
prendre un symbole et venir expliquer la
division convient aux dictatures moi ce
mot la mode mais c'est de cézanne dont
on parle ici avec vous et moi donc au
bape à l'autre chose moi ce mot-là en
france je ne peux pas l'entendre
après que vous trouvez ça choquant
peut-être que vous soyez ou aurait fixé
une famille qui a pas beaucoup de moyens
qui a une grosse amende
évidemment c'est injuste je suis
d'accord avec vous mais allez expliquer
que c'est une image de dictature moi je
ne veux pas entendre ça en france
la rega tir du lensois n'est pas saine
et naturelle à partir du moment où vous
explique
vous n'avez on vous enlève aux droits on
vous enlève votre liberté et donc ça
fait déjà plus le choix
c'était comme si on a pu voir les deux
pays dans le monde où ça le belge
aimerait qu'on voit une opportunité à
lire également une dictature ou le 44
pour son nom à 56 des cannibales et
équilibrée